so can I just ask are you okay with
homosexuals
what does that mean
a what homosexual Oh I thought you said
something okay I heard something
different I was like is that a new term
omnise
are you okay with homosexuals what does
that mean that's just we're doing okay
with it I know what homosexual is but
what do you mean by okay with it okay so
are they okay to decide that they like
someone of the opposite set but they
don't affect our lives of course they
are it's a free world oh okay so you can
be gay but you can't change your gender
when did I say that
you cannot literally change your sex
it's not possible just like just like
you can't fly you you can't change your
sex